when those of us in Ohio have not yet
had a solo a Star Wars story screening
we find folks go and see movies like
book club just when I thought I would
never have to say the words Fifty Shades
of Grey and a movie review ever again we
have the film book club which is about
four lifelong friends who get together
for a book club every once in awhile and
they have chosen to read the book Fifty
Shades of Grey
and in so doing they spice up their
rather slow-moving love lives now I know
you're probably thinking book club I'd
rather see a Deadpool to spoiler review
or a review of solo for instance which I
have not yet seen why are you reviewing
the movie that's basically aimed at
older audiences well this film is
stacked with legends Diane Keaton
Candice Bergen Mary Steenburgen Jane
Fonda Wallace Sean Richard Dreyfuss
Craig T Nelson this film has a lot of
talent in it that's why I wouldn't saw
it because I like pretty much all of
those actors quite a bit and sometimes
it's nice to go to a film and just relax
and not care that much about what you're
seeing and just have fun and I'm pretty
sure the majority of my senior citizen
filled movie theater did have fun
because many of them laughed and clapped
the entire time I found the film okay
the first half was actually surprisingly
funny Candice Bergen in particular as a
woman who has not dated in a very long
time she's a federal judge and now she's
on Bumble she's trying to figure out how
this dating app works and she's going on
dates with people like Richard Dreyfuss
or Wallace Sean and there's actually
quite a bit of good humor to be reaped
out of those sequences the storyline
with Andy Garcia and Diane Keaton was
pretty adorable and obviously there was
a slight novelty and seeing the veteran
actors who played nephew and aunt in
Godfather 3 back in a movie together and
Don Johnson is also in this film I
forgot and it's funny because his
daughter Dakota Johnson is the star of
the actual Fifty Shades of Grey movies
and it's just a weird connection that
doesn't really matter but the first half
of the movie actually had a lot of good
humor in it that I found enjoyable
seeing these older women read this book
and get these shocked looks on their
faces and then look at their
husbands and then get ideas the first
half of the movie actually sustains some
fairly enjoyable banter back and forth
between these women it made them really
feel like they've been friends forever
they could insult each other right to
their faces and they don't care and I
always love seeing old people insult
each other and they don't give a
there's something great about that us
young people we get so worked up about
everything but old people they don't
give a and I love that I really
like that aspect of this movie but about
halfway through the film just I don't
want to say it crashes and burns but it
just stops being interesting it stops
being funny
the novelty of seeing these women read
this book and then look at their
husbands and and get erotic ideas kind
of fades away and all of a sudden it
tries to be more serious and that's
where this film makes a lot of mistakes
first half of this movie was an
enjoyable relaxing experience the last
half was a bit taxing it just gets kind
of sad and depressing and there's still
some humor thrown throughout but as the
women start to look at the things about
their lives they don't like this is
usually where the film gets more
compelling and the characters become
something that maybe you didn't realize
they were but the film can't really
escape the fact that it's really a lot
of legendary actors reading kind of
basic material that really isn't all
that great and they're making it a lot
better than it is just because of their
charm but after a while that starts to
fade and the fact that that's really
just a movie with a sort of funny
concept rears its ugly head towards the
last half and the movie gets a lot less
funny I've said this in videos before
and I know other people have too I'm not
the right demographic for this movie but
I really don't think in the long run
that should matter I think film is
universal I think communicating to an
audience on an emotional level and
making them feel something that's
universal that's ageless yes certain
ages or demographics or genders are
going to get things out of films that
others may not because they relate to it
more but in the long run I think that
film is ageless and timeless and that it
should be appreciated by all if it's
good and certain aspects of this movie
you can really laugh at it but it just
starts to get old after
no pun intended and the storyline gets
so thin that it just wears on and on and
you're waiting for your stereotypical
romantic comedy endings to happen that
you all know are going to happen and
these legendary actors are able to carry
a lot more out of that first half but as
soon as that concept starts to wear thin
so does the rest of the movie and
surprisingly the book is barely really
part of the film it's just sort of like
something that instigates a change in
their lives and then they barely ever
talk about it again so if you were
concerned about tons of Fifty Shades of
Grey references you're not gonna get
that many yeah there are scenes where
characters do things that Anastasia
Steele and Christian Grey do in the
movies like Andy Garcia takes Diane
Keaton on a plane ride there's stuff
like that but I mean like for the most
part the book is rarely referenced and
we're left with a series of awkward and
embarrassing encounters where older
people are trying to find their mojo
again some of them are actually really
funny Craig T Nelson has a really good
scene he has an awkward comedic scene
involving viagra that goes on for far
too long
and it's kind of an obvious joke that
you can see coming a mile away but he
has a pretty good dramatic one that I
was actually really impressed with Diane
Keaton does a lot of her flailing her
arms around and kind of like muttering
things and you're just like picturing
the actual dialogue and like in
parentheses are this is where Diane
Keaton improv this is where Diane Keaton
improv and it doesn't really always work
she's a great actress but she has a
definite side to her that always comes
through in her characters where it just
seems like it's her and sometimes that
can be damaging to the character I think
most people aren't gonna give a to
be honest I think the majority of
audiences are going to go to this movie
and just laugh a little bit and then
leave all that being said I'm gonna give
book club a see started stronger than I
expected it to but as soon as that plot
fizzles away you still have half of a
movie left and it just doesn't have
anywhere to go guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon I appreciate it very
much you're the best and as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]